we typically aim for a particular career
because we've been deeply impressed by
the exploits of the most accomplished
practitioners in the field we formulate
our ambitions by admiring the beautiful
structures of the architect tasked with
designing the city's new airport or by
following the intrepid trades of the
wealthiest Wall Street fund manager by
reading the analyses of the acclaimed
literary novelist or cycling the piquant
meals in the restaurant of the prize
will never reform our career plans on
the basis of perfection then inspired by
the masters we take our own first steps
and the truffle Covina's
what we have managed to design or make
in our first month of trading or write
in an early short story or cook for the
family is markedly and absurdly beneath
the standard that first sparked our
ambitions we who are so aware of
excellence end up the least able to
tolerate mediocrity which in this case
happens to be our own we become stuck in
an uncomfortable paradox our ambitions
have being ignited by greatness but
everything we know of ourselves acquires
to congenital ineptitude we have fallen
into what we can term the perfectionist
trap defined as a powerful attraction to
perfection
Shaun of any mature or sufficient
understanding of what is actually
required to attain it it isn't primarily
our fault without in any way revealing
this or even perhaps being aware of it
our media edits out billions of
unremarkable lives and years of failure
rejection and frustration even in those
who do achieve in order to serve us up a
daily curated selection of peak career
moments which thereby end up seeming not
like the violent exceptions they
actually are but like a norm and
baseline of achievement it starts to
appear as though everyone is successful
because all those who we happen to hear
about really are successes and we have
forgotten to imagine the oceans of tears
and
that necessarily surround them our
perspective is imbalanced because we
know our own struggles so well from the
inside and yet are exposed to apparently
pain free narratives of achievement on
the outside you cannot forgive
themselves the horrors about early
drafts largely because we have not seen
the early drafts of those we admire we
need a saner picture of how many
difficulties lie behind everything we
would wish to emulate we should not look
for example at the masterpieces of art
in a museum we should go to the studio
and there see the anguish wrecked early
versions and watermarks on the paper
where the artists broke down and wept we
should focus on how long it took the
architect before they received their
first proper Commission they were over
50 we need to dig out the early stories
of the writer who now wins prizes and
examine more closely how many failures
the entrepreneur had to endure we need
to recognize the legitimate and
necessary role of failure allow
ourselves to do things quite imperfectly
for a very long time as a price we
cannot avoid paying for an opportunity
one day perhaps in many decades to do
something that others will consider a
spontaneous success
you